[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka
guten abend rund eine million gemeldeten
neuinfektionen bin eines tages diese
zahl hat auch die amerikaner heute
erschreckt obwohl man dort ja inzwischen
schon einiges gewohnt ist so heftig wie
omikron durchs land zieht zum vergleich
das wäre so als würde bei uns das rk ii
auf einen schlag etwa
250.000 neuinfektionen melden und kamen
in den usa aber auch einige
nachmeldungen nach den feiertagen
zusammen trotzdem die ansteckungsquelle
ist steil fast senkrecht wie der
bekannte us virologe anthony fauci sagt
und es trifft alle altersgruppen
benjamin daniel berichtet aus den usa
in texas größter kinderklinik kämpft
grayson ganz tapfer der vier monate alte
neugeborene hat sich mit coop 19
infiziert das atmen bereitet ihm
allergrößte schwierigkeiten
ich habe solche angst ich hoffe dass er
bald wieder nach hause kann
gabriel glaubt dass sich das jüngste
ihrer drei kinder bei einer
familienfeier zu weihnachten angesteckt
hat die situation macht sie hilflos
ich spreche in einer baby stände mit ihm
und singe ich kann zwar nicht gut singen
aber er mag es grayson ist nur eines von
knapp 70 kindern die zurzeit in diesem
krankenhaus wegen cupid 19 behandelt
werden in den letzten beiden wochen
haben sich die korona einweisungen hier
mehr als vervierfacht die meisten kinder
sind umkämpft
die schmerzgrenze verschiebt sich immer
weiter nach oben bei jeder neuen welle
denken wir das schaffen wir nicht noch
einmal und dann machen wir es doch
wieder es bleibt ihnen wohl auch nichts
anderes übrig denn die zahlen steigen
weiter und das nicht nur in texas
insgesamt wurden heute in den usa rund
eine millionen neuinfektionen gemeldet
mehr als 95 prozent davon sind auf die
omikron variante zurückzuführen die
kritik an joe biden herr schätze die
lage zugelassen ein wird lauter die
knappen test kapazitäten sind nur eines
von vielen problemen der us präsident
äußerte sich vor etwa zwei stunden
wenn sie die impf und gepolstert sind
haben sie einen hervorragenden schutz
sie sollten wege nikon besorgt aber
nicht alarmiert
mehr und mehr auch geimpfte sind jedoch
durchaus alarmiert und fordern jetzt
auch schulschließungen zumindest bis der
höhepunkt der aktuellen welle
überschritten ist new yorks neuer
bürgermeister sieht das anders
ja natürlich sehen wir steigende
fallzahlen wir sehen wie schnell uns
diese variante ergreift aber es ist doch
auch klar es wird immer wieder neue
varianten geben und wir können unsere
kinder nicht weiter davon abhalten sich
sozial und akademisch zu entwickeln wir
müssen sie unterstützen und lernen mit
kurve zu leben und dafür müssen wir
einen möglichst sicheren weg finden
die verantwortlichen im texas children's
hospital rechnen damit dass sich die
situation in den nächsten wochen weiter
verschlimmern wird auch wenn die omikron
variante grundsätzlich zu milden
verläufen führt als vorige mutanten des
virus
die fallzahlen bei kindern und
erwachsenen sind einfach so hoch dass
wir selbst wenn die hospitalisierung
rate im verhältnis geringer ist wir
trotzdem viel mehr einweisungen in einem
sehr kurzen zeitraum haben und das ist
natürlich eine immense belastung unseres
gesundheitssystems
führende us geologen rechnen damit dass
der höhepunkt der welle noch im januar
überschritten werden könnte amerika
hofft dass sie recht behalten
sie haben und hier kann man nur hoffen
dass der blick in die usa keinen blick
in unsere nähere zukunft ist die
deutsche politik richtet sich jedenfalls
auf rasant steigende zahlen ein der
expertenrat der bundesregierung berät
heute über künftige regeln bei der
quarantäne für kontaktpersonen und der
isolation für infizierte morgen sollen
dazu dann die gesundheitsminister tagen
verschonen wird uns die omikron welle
jedenfalls ganz sicher nicht die zahl
nachgewiesener und mikron fälle hat sich
innerhalb einer woche bereits
verdreifacht in den nächsten tagen
werden auch die insgesamt gemeldeten
infektionszahlen wieder präziser sein
dann wird sich der feiertags nebel
verzogen haben eines dürfte sicher sein
ein lockern der eindämmung maßnahmen
wird es so bald nicht geben dara
hassanzadeh und dalian tag richten
sie nennen sich spaziergänger laufen als
protest gegen die korona maßnahmen kreuz
und quer durch die stadt wie hier
gestern abend den mann
[Applaus]
in kleinen aber lauten gruppen sie
entstammen aus unterschiedlichen milieus
ihnen gemeinsam ist ein feindbild
bestehend aus staat wissenschaft und
medien wir sehen uns gegner teilweise
eben auch gruppierungen die dafür
mobilisieren die auch schon vor corinna
radikal gegen impfungen waren anhänger
aus dem esoterik mühe aber natürlich
eben auch rechtsextremisten was diese
menschen eint ist ganz klar das
feindbild und an die feindbilder lauten
medien politik aber eben auch
wissenschaft das heißt man sieht sich
eben mit einer großen verschwörung
konfrontiert mancherorts wie in
magdeburg schlägt der sogenannte
spaziergang in gewalt um und doch sind
solche bilder kein endgültiger beweis
für eine gesellschaftliche spaltung
dieses spaltung star aktiv das halte ich
für falsch weil es immer so suggeriert
dass es zwei gleich große lager gibt die
sich irgendwie unversöhnlich gegenüber
stehen und was man da übersieht ist dass
wir mittlerweile in ganz vielen dingen
auch die die pandemie betreffenden viel
größeren konsens haben als zu beginn der
pandemie das bestätigen zahlen 85
prozent der deutschen sind geimpft
masken pflicht im nahverkehr und corinna
regeln am arbeitsplatz gesellschaftlich
akzeptiert das rkw vermeldet heute über
30.000 neuinfektionen was 9500 mehr als
vor einer woche
356 menschen starben an oder mit corona
die inzidenz liegt bei 239 9 und doch
ist das coroner lagebild in deutschland
unvollständig zu unterschiedlich sind
test auf kopf und melde
geschwindigkeiten im norden verbreitet
sich omikron dynamisch die sorge geht um
das neue quarantäne regeln weite teile
der infrastruktur
lahmlegen könnte
also ich denke es wird wichtig sein noch
einmal über das thema der quarantäne zu
reden gerade im hinblick auf die
kritische infrastruktur
man wird dort abwägen müssen zwischen
infektionsschutz und der
funktionsfähigkeit des lebens
letztendlich auch das eine wichtige
entscheidung auf die warten wir auch in
den ländern hamburg und schleswig
holstein haben bereits heute ihre corona
maßnahmen verschärft es wird wie ein
vorbote auf die morgige konferenz der
gesundheitsminister
mehr informationen rund um corona finden
sie bei uns natürlich wie immer auch
online auf zdf heute dort finden sie
unter anderem eine vorausschau wie sich
das jahr
2022 hierzulande in sachen corona
entwickeln könnte könnte wohlgemerkt
denn omikron hatten wir im letzten jahr
ja auch nicht auf dem schirm jetzt macht
erstmal heinz weiter auch mit einer
vorausschau rund sechs wochen vor der
bundespräsidentenwahl haben sich auch
die grünen für eine zweite amtszeit von
frank walter steinmeier ausgesprochen
die partei und fraktionsspitzen der
grünen riefen zur wiederwahl steinmeiers
auf und erklärten er ist ein sehr guter
und hoch angesehener bundespräsident der
sich in seiner amtszeit große verdienste
um unser land erworben hat spd und fdp
hatten sich bereits für steinmeier
ausgesprochen und die drei parteien der
ampel koalition habe mit der
bundesversammlung eine rechnerische
mehrheit
bundesarbeitsminister heil sieht den
arbeitsmarkt durch die korona pandemie
zwar erschüttert ein großes beben habe
man aber abwenden können so heil die
bundesagentur für arbeit registrierte
für dezember zwei millionen 330.000
arbeitslose 12.000 mehr als im november
die quote liegt unverändert bei 5,1
prozent verglichen mit dem dezember des
vorjahres ging die zahl der arbeitslosen
um
378.000 zurück
ein bisher geheimes kirchen dokument aus
dem die wochenzeitung die zeit zitiert
und das auch dem zdf vorliegt legt
vorwürfe einer pflichtverletzung des
früheren papst benedikt der 16 mal in
seiner zeit als erzbischof von münchen
und freising soll er es in den 1980 er
jahren versäumt haben sexualisierte
gewalt durch einen priester zu ahnden
der privatsekretär des ehemaligen
papstes als bischof georg gänswein weist
das zurück da er von den vorwürfen
sexueller übergriffe keine kenntnis
hatte bestand auch keine pflicht zur
meldung nach rom die er hätte verletzen
können derzeit ist ein gutachten zum
umgang mit missbrauchsvorwürfen des
erzbistums in arbeit das die erzdiözese
münchen freising in auftrag gegeben hat
die veröffentlichung ist für ende januar
geplant mehr über die zdf recherche
haben wir online und in der zdf- heute-
app für sie zusammengefasst
im sudan hat die militärführung nach dem
überraschenden rücktritt von
ministerpräsident han druck die bildung
einer nach eigenen angaben unabhängigen
regierung angekündigt tausende gingen
auch heute in mehreren städten gegen die
militärregierung auf die straße und
hauptstadt khartum wurde auch tränengas
eingesetzt
die demonstranten fordern die bildung
einer rein zivilen regierung bis zu den
geplanten wahlen im juli 2000 23
ein heftiger schneesturm hat an der
ostküste der usa gewütet
stromleitungen sind unter der schnee und
eislast zusammengebrochen oder durch
herabfallende äste abgerissen worden
hunderttausende haushalte sind von der
stromversorgung abgeschnitten
mehr als 14 stunden war der verkehr auf
einer autobahn im bundesstaat virginia
zum erliegen gekommen hunderte fahrer
steckten fest darunter auch tim kaine
senator des bundesstaates auch in der
nahe gelegenen hauptstadt washington dc
brachten knapp 30 zentimeter neuschnee
das öffentliche leben zum stillstand
400.000 neue wohnungen im jahr hat die
ampelkoalition als zielvorgabe
ausgegeben das ist ehrgeizig denn wir
leben ja bereits in einem ziemlich dicht
besiedelten land und dort wo wohnungsnot
herrscht in großen städten gibt es nicht
mehr viele freie flächen vor allem nicht
solche auf die die städte selbst zugriff
hätten auch hier machen sich die fehler
der vergangenheit bemerkbar berlin ist
sicher ein besonders prägnantes beispiel
dafür wie wohnungen und flächen verkauft
wurden um kurzfristig leere kassen zu
füllen heute würde man das gerne
rückgängig machen aber auch in anderen
kommunen ärgert man sich rückblickend
über so manche frühere fehlentscheidung
und versucht jetzt gegenzusteuern zb die
stadt neuss von dort berichtet tadeusz
parade
eine riesige unbebaute fläche mitten in
der neusser innenstadt insgesamt fünf
hektar groß obwohl das baurecht für die
ehemalige industriefläche längst erteilt
wurde ist hier jahrelang nichts passiert
für den neusser baudezernenten christoph
hölters ist der anblick nur schwer zu
ertragen wenn wir vor sechs jahren als
stadt hätten kaufen können dann kann man
davon ausgehen dass jetzt hier schon
baukräne zu sehen wären im sinne der
entwicklung dieses quartiers für 800
wohneinheiten an zentralste mord jetzt
ist es so dass die fläche
zwischenzeitlich zwei mal verkauft wurde
und wir in guten gesprächen mit dem
letzten käufer jetzt sind im rat gab es
damals keine mehrheit für den kauf des
grundstücks die stadt hätte es für 3,5
millionen euro erwerben können ein
schnäppchen für das was es heute wert
ist fehler aus denen man ein neues
gelernt
wo immer es möglich ist wird jetzt
gebaut
das neue wohnquartier im augustiner
viertel ist so gut wie fertig knapp
sechs euro durchschnittsmiete pro
quadratmeter zahlt hier dann eine
familie mit mittlerem einkommen möglich
auch die städtische
wohnungsbaugesellschaft regie führt ein
großteil der wohnungen ist öffentlich
gefördert unser auftrag als neusser
bauverein ist seit 130 jahren die
schaffung von bezahlbarem wohnraum für
alle bevölkerungsschichten neues und
natürlich treten da am markt halt auch
ganz normal gegen andere private
investoren an und müssen uns da
entsprechend durchsetzen doch der
künftige bedarf an neuen wohnungen ist
noch lange nicht gedeckt und geeignete
flächen sind rar im stadtgebiet
33 sind laut flächennutzungsplan für
wohnungsbau geeignet für 14 dieser
flächen hat sich die stadt neuss erst
vor kurzem ein vorkaufsrecht gesichert
ein wirkungsvolles instrument mit dem
die stadt sicherstellen kann dass auf
diesen flächen auch preiswerter wohnraum
entsteht
ein vorkaufsrecht satzungen gelingt es
uns jetzt etwa 50 prozent des wohnung wo
man an potenzial bis 2030 so entwickeln
zu können das sind 3000 von 6.000
wohneinheiten das entspricht schon mehr
als dem was in den letzten zehn jahren
errichtet wurde ist aber immer noch
deutlich weniger als das was sie
errichten müssen damit der wohnungsmarkt
entlastet wird dass kommunen beim
vorkaufsrecht künftig noch mehr
spielraum eingeräumt werden soll plant
auch die neue bundesbauministerium
ebenso wenn sie grundstück spekulationen
einen riegel vorschieben
wir werden weiter daran gehen
spekulationen in dem bereich zu
reduzieren indem wir zum beispiel
verbieten dass man grundstücke mit
bargeld bezahlt indem wir den
grundbucheintrag verbessern aber auch
andere maßnahmen sind notwendig dass die
kommunen in der lage sind bau gebote
auszusprechen in ihrem bereich ist zum
beispiel sehr sehr wichtig auch dass man
einzelne schrottimmobilien an kaufen
kann und dass die kommunen das was das
grundgesetz vor liegt nämlich dass seine
planungshoheit haben in ihrem bereich
auch wirklich leben können
die zeit maßloser preistreiberei müsse
beendet werden sagte auch der neusser
baudezernent der wert des
filetgrundstück sein neues ist in
wenigen jahren von 35 auf 40 millionen
euro in die höhe getrieben worden mit
solchen preisen ist bezahlbarer wohnraum
unmöglich
eine billion mark dafür kann man im
november 1923 gerade mal ein laib brot
für eine straßenbahnfahrt musste man 50
milliarden hinlegen die erfahrung mit
der hyperinflation war so krass dass wir
uns deutschen heute noch in den knochen
steckt auch wenn es kaum noch menschen
gibt die sich selbst daran erinnern
können etwa wie geldscheine in säcken
durch die gegend gekappt wurden was der
erste weltkrieg an kapital noch nicht
vernichtet hatte schaffte die inflation
die angst davor ist also wohl begründet
in der türkei kann man sich derzeit
ansehen was eine zu starke inflation
bedeutet auch wenn es dort noch lange
nicht so schlimm ist wie einst dem
deutschen reich die türkische
bevölkerung leidet jetzt schon sehr gut
ausgehen wird das wohl nicht noch weiter
berichtet aus der türkei sie kommen mit
den preisschildern nicht mehr nach
gestern noch acht heute schon zehn
lehrer für den döner tomaten kartoffeln
die preise galoppieren 44 prozent
anstieg bei lebensmitteln in einem monat
fisch und fleisch werden selbst für
bürger mit normalem einkommen zum luxus
frustration und unmut machen sich breit
getränke zu teuer gemüse zu teuer bot
jetzt vier lehrer das kann ich mir nicht
leisten
strom wasser gas rechnungen dafür geht
fast die ganze rente drauf so kann es
nicht weitergehen
der kunde der zwei kilo gekauft hat
nimmt jetzt ein halbes kilo oder fast
gar nicht mehr rein wir zu hause kaufen
kann fleisch mehr
ein grund für die teuerung die türkische
lira verliert immer mehr an wert auf ein
staatspräsident erdogan in seiner
eigenwilligen finanz politik festhält
bei steigender inflation heben
notenbanken in aller welt in der regel
die zinsen an um geld teurer zu machen
erdogan macht das gegenteil
er diktierte der zentralbank immer
weitere senkungen des leitzinses derzeit
14 prozent die folge die unabhängigkeit
der zentralbank ist praktisch
abgeschafft und mit ihr das vertrauen
der anleger wer noch lehrer im
sparstrumpf hat der rettet sich in
dollar oder euro eine spirale die für
millionen türken immer dramatischer wird
gestern räumte erdogan erstmals ein dass
ein kurs wohl noch nicht so richtig
erfolgreich ist
was immer der grund ist wir bedauern
dass unsere bürger mit so einer lage
konfrontiert sind und wir sind fest
entschlossen die inflation so schnell
wie möglich wieder in den einstelligen
bereich zu bringen
den grund kennt allerdings so ziemlich
jeder im land oppositionsführer
kilicdaroglu nennt ihn beim namen
wer hat die preiserhöhungen
herbeigeführt erdogan wer durch die
bürger an und sagt er werde die preise
bekämpfen erdogan
es könnte ein unruhiges jahr für den
präsidenten werden während er die
arabischen monarchien auf der suche nach
frischem geld umwirbt schmelzen seine
beliebtheitswerte zu hause fast so
schnell wie der wert der lehrer
meinungsforscher sehen seine partei noch
bei 32 prozent dicht gefolgt von der
opposition im nächsten jahr sind wahlen
der präsident setzt auf ausgeleierte
durchhalteparolen
auch wenn die nation derzeit leidet wir
werden diese schwierigkeiten schnell
überwinden und zu den zehn größten
wirtschaftsnationen der welt gehören für
die menschen die schon jetzt mit ihrem
geld nicht mehr hinkommen klingt das wie
blanker hohn
es wird jeden tag schlimmer aus der
krise kommen wir nicht mehr raus zeit
zum wechseln
eine meinung die immer mehr seiner
landsleute teil
und von uns noch eine korrektur in
unserem bericht über die korona lage in
deutschland hat er sich eine falsche
zahl eingeschlichen vollständig geimpft
hier in deutschland sind nicht 85
prozent wie es hieß sondern
71,3 prozent bitten das zu entschuldigen
und jetzt geht es weiter bei 1 mit dem
blick auf die deutsche wirtschaft das
statistische bundesamt meldet für das
vergangene jahr einen rekordumsatz im
einzelhandel in deutschland das ergebe
eine schätzung nach den vorläufigen
daten die aber auch zeigen frank
bethmann dass es in den verschiedenen
handelsbereichen deutliche unterschiede
gibt ja richtig und so tut man sich
wirklich schwer von einer gesamtbilanz
zu sprechen zu groß die unterschiede wie
kaum eine andere branche hatte
einzelhandel in deutschland zwei total
verschiedene gesichter da freuen sich
die supermärkte die drogisten und vor
allem der internet und versandhandel
über einen erneut boomendes
geschäftsjahr 20 21 gleichzeitig drängt
das zweite corona jahr in folge vor
allem viele bekleidungs und
schuhgeschäfte in den innenstädten an
den rand der existenz der handelsverband
hde spricht von teilweise großer not
nicht nur dass die kunden angesichts
hoher instanzen die innenstadt läden
meiden gerade im weihnachtsgeschäft
klagten viele geschäfte zusätzlich über
lieferengpässe fast 82 prozent der
einzelhändler konnten nicht alle
produkte anbieten besonders
elektronische haushaltsgeräte und
unterhaltungselektronik
waren knapp sehr viel eindeutiger das
bild derzeit am aktienmarkt der dax
klettert weiter nach oben heute um 132
punkte auf 16.100
53 zähler nicht wenige spekulieren
darauf dass das aktienbarometer noch in
dieser woche ein neues allzeithoch
markieren wird frank wittmann vielen
dank gerne es gibt eine unwetterwarnung
des deutschen wetterdienstes vor
ergiebigem dauerregen für teile von
baden-württemberg
in innsbruck an der bergisel schanze war
ist heute der starke wind der probleme
machte das dritte tourneespringen dass
dort stattfinden sollte musste abgesagt
werden dafür soll es nun in
bischofshofen zwei wettbewerbe geben
nach drei stunden des wartens die
gewissheit
sandro pertile der renndirektor sagte
den wettbewerb ab der wind am bergisel
zu gefährlich die deutsche jagd auf den
tournee führenden rio kobayashi
verschoben beide ausstehenden springen
finden in bischofshofen statt
kobayashi ist einfach springt so gut
momentan das ist egal ist auf der
schanze springt es kann nur wunder
geschehen glaube dass man nur ein holz
aber wir bereiten uns so vor dass wenn
das wunder geschieht dann wollen wir die
ersten sein die sie diesen platz zu
übernehmen können bischofshofen ist eine
flieger chance die dem japaner entgegen
kommt doch auch der toni vierter markus
eisenbichler springt dort gern zwölf
meter rückstand muss er aufholen der
tross zieht weiter der tournee ausgang
ist weiter offen
das deutsche tennis team hat beim atp-
cup in sydney die chance auf den einzug
ins halbfinale gewahrt durch ein 2 1
gegen die usa die nur das doppel
gewannen in den beiden einzeln gingen
alexander zverev und jan lennard struff
als sieger vom platz
bei der letzten etappe der tour de ski
km langlauf für friedrich noch
überraschend auf einen podestplatz der
21 jährige erreichte nach dem steilen
schlussanstieg in val di fiemme als
dritter das ziel und lucas bögl
komplettierte als vierter das
erstklassige deutsche tagesergebnis
gesamtsieger der tour der norweger
johannes klapper
kein geringerer als der ehemalige
präsident des weltskiverbandes und ihrem
mitglied des ioc gian franco kasper
sagte vor einigen jahren in einem
gespräch mit dem deutschlandfunk in
autoritären staaten sei die ausrichtung
olympischer spiele einfacher zitat wenn
wir eine diktatur haben ist die sache
viel leichter
das nennt man dann wohl ein wahres wort
gelassen ausgesprochen
in diktaturen gibt es halt keinen
widerstand gegen solche
großveranstaltungen wie etwa in münchen
seinerzeit die münchner bevölkerung
wollte die winterspiele 2022 dort ja
nicht haben stattdessen wurden sie nach
china vergeben dort war auch kein
protest zu befürchten gegen die
brachialen methoden mit denen dafür im
wüstenklima pekings künstliche
skigebiete erschaffen werden christiane
hofmann berichtet
zehn liter pro sekunde sprühen die
schneekanonen auf die olympische
skipiste seit mitte november quasi rund
um die uhr olympia soll strahlend weiß
glänzen winterwelt doch die realität ist
er braun grau denn in den bergen von
peking schneit es fast nie das wasser
kommt aus weit entfernten sehen und wird
über dutzende kilometer in die berge
gepumpt auf den skipisten sorgen der
österreicher manuel schöpf und sein team
für den schnee und das bei starkem wind
und temperaturen bis minus 25 grad
[Musik]
mehr als zwei millionen kubikmeter
wasser werden sie für die olympischen
pisten brauchen und das in einer
wasserarmen region für wissenschaftler
sind die neuen pisten schlicht
umweltsünden denn bobbahn und alpine
abfahrt liegen in einem
naturschutzgebiet
nach der entscheidung für waging
2022 wurde das gebiet kurzerhand
verändert die berge mit rodelbahn und
alpine abfahrt aus ihm heraus gelöst
proteste von wissenschaftlern nützt
nichts das ist natürlich sehr
problematisch weil die skipisten die
sind in der nicht nur im
naturschutzgebiet sondern der kern zone
das ist also die absolut höchste wert ja
und das olympische village das
olympische dorf ist in der randzone aber
beides ist eben nicht vertretbar die
olympia-macher verteidigen ihre
entscheidung nennen ihre spiele
nachhaltig
wir haben spezielle maßnahmen ergriffen
um die umwelt zu schützen wir haben
pflanzen und bäume von den skipisten in
andere gebiete umgepflanzt
gezeigt werden uns diese projekte
allerdings nicht durch den starken
eingriff in die landschaft fürchtet
geografen der jung langfristige folgen
die erosion vielleicht sogar
gerölllawine
ich denke das werden die eu nach nächste
spiele aller zeiten was der schnee
angeht denn wasserverbrauch den co2
ausstoß respekt von naturschutzgebieten
erosion es gibt viele viele viele
aspekte die nicht nachhaltig sind
peking ist der weltweit erste ort der
nach sommer jetzt auch winterspiele
austragen und das offenbar um jeden
preis
das war es im heute journal gleich nach
dem wetter folgt markus lanz mit seiner
doku über die usa amerika ungeschminkt
sie knüpft an die dokumentation an die
eher 2017 drehte am ende des ersten
amtsjahres von donald beide filme sind
natürlich auch in der mediathek abrufbar
und um 0.30 gibt es an unserer
heute-journal update mit gundula gause
auf wiedersehen wieder sind
[Musik]
genannt das tief annette hat bereits
viel regen mitgebracht es sieht morgen
weiter nach osten aber es gibt schon ein
neues tief barbara das peilt morgen
island an dazwischen aber gibt es ein
kleines zwischenhoch das ist dieses hoch
alex dass uns am donnerstag geehrt heute
nacht aber fällt noch viel regen und
dieser regen geht jetzt immer mehr in
schnee über jedenfalls in den höheren
lagen der mittelgebirge und auch am
alpenrand morgen gibt's dann kräftige
schauer und dann kommt der donnerstag
der wird ein bisschen freundlicher aber
schon am freitag kommt ein neues
tieferen das bringt schnee und regen
heran heute nacht also für das nochmal
kräftig regnen den nordschwarzwald in
den mittelgebirgen und am alpenrand geht
der regen mehr und mehr in schnee über
und an der nordseeküste sind auch einige
schneeregen oder graupel gewitter nicht
ganz ausgeschlossen machen sie sich auf
gefährlich glatte straßen gefasst denn
fast überall ist es kalt genug für
glätte mit tiefsttemperaturen zwischen
plus 3 und minus zwei grad die
höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen meist
bei 45 grad kälter bleibt ist in den
mittelgebirgen etwas milder wird das an
der nordsee morgen vormittag fällt noch
schnee regen im südosten bayerns es gibt
einen freundlichen streifen von der
uckermark bis richtung saarland und
oberrhein und im nordwesten gibt es
kräftige schauer zum teil auch gewitter
an der nordseeküste der wind dazu ist
rechtkräftig er kommt aus westlichen
richtungen am nachmittag wird zieht sich
der etwas freundlicher streifen nach
süden in schleswig holstein kommt
strahlend die sonne zum vorschein am
donnerstag wird es dann in ganz
deutschland recht freundlich am freitag
droht von westen schon wieder neuer
schnee und regen am guten abend